Think you've seen all the best lightsaber
battles in the galaxy far, far away?
Well, think again.
The glowing, lightly humming blade has been
the staple weapon of the Star Wars franchise
since its inception in the late 1970s.
But somehow, despite all the lightsaber fights
that fans of the films have seen over the
years, there's one that still hasn't been
shared with the world.
And it's apparently the best one ever.
Nick Gillard, the stunt coordinator for the
Star Wars prequel trilogy, recently revealed
to Entertainment Weekly that he had mapped
out a lightsaber battle so incredible, it
would have trumped the one between Obi-Wan
Kenobi, Qui-Gon Jinn, and Darth Maul in The
Phantom Menace.
He explained that the lightsaber fight that
took place on Utapau in Revenge of the Sith,
during which Obi-Wan battles against General
Grievous and his bodyguards, looked a little
different in the original version of the film.
Before ridding the galaxy of General Grievous,
Obi-Wan first needs to dispense of his bodyguards.
The theatrical cut of Revenge of the Sith
sees the Jedi Master using the Force to pull
a piece of the ceiling down on five of the
six bodyguards Grievous sets on him.
However, the original version of that scene
would have featured an elaborate battle royale.
Unfortunately, when it came down to it, the
production was so far behind on filming that
they couldn't afford the amount of time the
sequence was going to take to shoot.
Lucas had to make a difficult decision.
Given that the lightsaber battle wasn't integral
to the narrative, he decided to drastically
cut down on the scene's filming time by simplifying
the scene.
With Grievous' bodyguards fighting with their
electro-staffs and Obi-Wan wielding his signature
lightsaber, the scene promises at the outset
to be an electrified battle.
The final version does see Obi-Wan brace himself
for a kind of all-or-nothing fight, but it
falls a bit flat when he disposes of them
so unceremoniously.
One of the bodyguards survives Obi-Wan's trickery,
leaving the Jedi master to quickly behead
him in what we can only assume is a highly
watered-down version of the original battle.
If the sequence played out like Gillard had
intended it to, it would have been infinitely
cooler.
Despite sounding like the most epic lightsaber
battle of the Star Wars canon thus far, fans
have never seen it.
Sadly for them, it likely doesn't exist in
a cinematic capacity, given that Gillard seems
to be implying that the scene never even made
it to the front of the camera.
Still, as disappointing as Gillard's revelation
may be, Revenge of the Sith is full of some
awesome lightsaber battles that many of the
other Star Wars films lack.
Even if they didn't get a brawl with Obi-Wan,
the bodyguards get some action at the beginning
of Revenge of the Sith when Anakin and Obi-Wan
infiltrate Grievous' spaceship to rescue Palpatine
from Count Dooku.
They even seem far more impressive than their
later defeat would seem to imply as they manage
to hold off Anakin and Obi-Wan long enough
for Grievous to make a dramatic exit.
That set piece also featured an impressive
battle between Anakin and the sith lord Count
Dooku.
Obi-Wan later fights Grievous and finally
gets rid of him, Mace Windu battles against
Palpatine, and even Yoda has his own action-packed
faceoff against Palpatine in the senate.
Plus, fans are treated to a brutally emotional
stand-off between Obi-Wan and Anakin on Mustafar
after he discovers his former Padawan has
gone to the dark side.
Though George Lucas may have cut the best
lightsaber fight in all of Star Wars history
from Revenge of the Sith, he definitely didn't
skimp on Jedi action.
Whether or not the upcoming Star Wars flick
The Rise of Skywalker will provide fans with
a lightsaber battle to fill the void of the
missing scene from Revenge of the Sith is
yet to be seen.
Still, based on the high-flying lightsaber
battles of The Last Jedi and The Force Awakens,
we're not worried.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.